the floors yours thank you
so today I will talk about how we can do
fast text processing in Python using
rustic sanctions but also more broadly
how we can build rest extensions to for
high-performance pies and if she worries
about myself so I'm my background in
physics I was doing computational plasma
physics before and now I'm I'm working
as an independent consultant on data
science and I'm also an active second
open-source contributor in particular to
psychic learn and to pilot projects
which I will mention later so let's look
at how a scientific patent ecosystem has
been traditionally built to be
high-performance essentially we have a
let's look at site by for instance so
Syfy has like around half half in the
new lines of code of Python
it has 24% of Fortran 19% of C and a bit
of C++ and essentially the performant
parts are due to those compiled
languages in particular Fortran and C
and interestingly if you look at how
often those felt change we don't see
that python file changed much more often
than C your fart fortune for instance
fortune on average it was contributed
maybe six years ago and nobody actually
touched it since I mean it works it's
very stable it's very like robust but
but it also means that we are we're
missing some of the like performance
improvements we could get just because
maybe the algorithms could be written
better or things could be done better
and so it's it's it's I mean it applies
to site bye-bye I'm sure it also applies
to another and a set of other libraries
so what are the alternatives well there
is a number a number of alternatives
that you can use for instance a popular
one is site on so we will write a sudo
python code that will be compiled to C
and then build as a extension patron
Moomba just-in-time compiler and
essentially all of those work really
well however they're they're very
interlinked with Python what I mean
minimize that is that
you're part of the Python ecosystem and
it means that you cannot use actual
libraries builds outside of this
ecosystem or likely make use of other
libraries unlike if you go for instance
into C or C++
of course there you can like you can use
libraries developed by other people you
don't have to do everything from scratch
I mean it also applies to seitan but
just broad idea and and more recently
you can actually also build extensions
using rust and this is the subject of
this talk so just a quick show hands who
has used rust before here great who has
heard it first okay so rust is a
high-performance assistant programming
language which focuses on memory safety
and in particular and safe concurrency
which is important if you want to do
high-performance computing so one one
permanent feature for us is it has a
package manager meaning that you can
when you want to use some functionality
you can just you know you don't have to
manually compile or build something as
you would do in C or C++ it uses that
automatic memory management at
compilation time so it means that you
don't have a garbage collector but
memory is going to be allocated and
deallocate it depending on its use in in
in the code at the compilation time so
this is useful if you want to enter late
like if you want to link it with with
another language such as Python because
python has its own garbage collection
and it means that because Rus doesn't
have one it's easier to make them
communicate essentially and also another
nice feature is is that you can detect
like vectorized instructions at runtime
so it means that you can make a single
binary and depending on the on the cpu
you're going to run it it's going to use
the right CPU instructions to be faster
so and this is more or less transparent
to you so if you use just some
dependencies that do this you
automatically get the benefited and so
now let's talk about writing extensions
for Python interests so essentially the
main the main
project we're going to use is pi/3 which
provides those bindings to the C Python
interpreter it also what works for pi PI
by the way and then we have the rest
numpy project which which provides
bindings to the children pc by CP so
there is also a young but growing
ecosystem of scientific packages around
this one one small issue is that for now
pilot requires rust unstable so you
can't use it on the stable branch of
thrust which is not that great for
production systems but yeah so let's
let's do a simple example we'll want to
say some a vector so we will just take a
view into this array of a float 64 64
here and we'll apply the sum operator in
from the NVRA library so in the arrays
is like an equivalent of numpy for
forests and actually people who wrote it
they also have a this convenient mapping
of different functions so for instance
you want to do I don't know you want to
do a recreation so then in anybody with
this and and in the array with that so
it also gives you some idea of death of
the syntax of how you can map your your
computations in one or another so I
don't know there's like all this
standard and by operations and then
slicing and and then like basic
mathematical operations so so we have
now this function in rust right so I
mean here it's a very simple simple
piece of code but you can imagine like
building a more complete additional
pipeline and then we want to use it in
Python so we'll just write write a
wrapper for it in in pi 3 the wrapper in
this case would look something like this
so it's a bit there is a bit of
boilerplate code here but I mean if you
have written wrappers in like in C
you'll know that it's not necessarily
very very pretty but the point is that
it will will allow you to to create a a
Python module and sorry about a model
that you can done in Porton Python and
past an empire array and it's going to
like return the result so this is the
basic idea and then the question is so
that the project I'm going to present is
how we can apply this on a particular
example of of text the text
vectorization so what is texture ization
is essentially how we take a document
and convert it to a sparse sparse matrix
that we can do actually machine learning
on later on so the basic pipeline is we
take this document we apply some
pre-processing some tokenization to
convert the document tokens then
potentially we concatenate tokens
together to get engrams and then finally
we count we count this tokens into a
sparse sparse matrix so so it's like
very the very basic thing in in node and
for instance if you look in the Python
ecosystem those this is for instance
can't be done with psychic learn with
the glass is called contactor Iser and
Hashem vectorizer
so the Hashem vectorizer what it does it
additionally applies hash functions or
tokens so we can reduce the size of the
vocabulary and I have been essentially
looking at for some time into how we can
make those two classes faster because
this is often a bottleneck in terms of
you have a large document collection you
want to just apply some basic you know
linear model in it and just just extract
tokens can take a while so so if you
look at the history of contributions in
scikit-learn they have been like a lot
of small contributions incremental
things to tune out the performance there
and over the last several years but
however it was never like the
performance kind of reached the max the
optimum at the moment end unless there
is like major changes it's not going to
get improved so what you can do you can
also for instance you rewrite token
counting insight on so this is already
done for hashing vectorizer and
unfortunately we can see that in this
particular case it doesn't actually
improve the performance that much
because part of the pipeline is still in
pure pile then also the problem is if
you
if you want to write it in sight and it
means that you have to handle Unicode
and basically you have to handle Unicode
in C which is not something at least
personally I would like to do in my free
time and and also another thing is
tokenization is the bottleneck
so the tokenization is just uses the
regex icon library and so basically this
is one of the bottlenecks that we it's a
bit hard to address so another approach
could be to to use parallelization with
tasks so this works well for instance in
the case of hashing achter Iser which is
stateless it means that it doesn't have
a state and you can apply it basically
to chunks of the data set independently
so here with this map partition function
and then concatenate the result and
you'll get the essentially result on
your full data set so this works but
it's let's say it's it's it still work
around around the fact that the our
basic transformation function is a bit
slow so so the question I was wondering
about can we actually make it a bit
faster by writing a rest extension so
first nice comment like observation was
that if we just use the so the basic
tokenization is just you call ax with
some expression and you apply the final
function so this directly calls to the C
Python implementation of Bri module
right and actually if you if you do the
same thing a rest and like with
including the Python wrapper just this
is going to be twice faster because rust
has a bit more and your implementation
of regex but it's a bit better at moment
and also there is nice packages such as
for instance Unicode segmentation so
Unicode segmentation is a spec on how we
how we basically all tokenize sentences
and into into words and if you apply
this just like the basic package in rust
with a few additional rules in a sense
there are a few NLP specific rules of
how to you should talk a nice text for
instance if you look at the this
sentence the can't it's usually
organizes CA and
to like to denote the net negation but
anyway so this you have to add it
additionally because Unicode
segmentation it doesn't handle it but
and then you get something which is
essentially reasonably fast so if you
compare it for instance to to the Python
reg X version just above it's it's it's
twice faster if you just use their
gaxton rest if you use this more
complicated unicode segmentation thing
you'll get equivalent performance
however if you then look at the accuracy
so here we measure measure the accuracy
on the universal dependencies tree back
and you'll see that the reg X get a f1
score of 0-8 on English or in French for
instance for instance if you compare to
space C species really good it has a lot
of like more advanced rules it gets a
pretty good f1 score here but in terms
of performance you get a bit lower
because you have a lot of like manual
rules that need to be checked and
actually like we tax this package so
you'll get a pretty good f1 scores well
the performance actually also
significant higher of course I mean this
benchmarks a bit preliminary so we that
here the essential the rules have been
tuned to get the score high so so Spacey
does a lot more things than the text but
like it's just a illustration of how you
can Kentucky nice text so let's let's
look into a bit into detail what we need
to do to do token County so for instance
one of the things that's nice
in terms of workflow is that imagine
you're in you know you write your
function inside on so and then you need
a hash function so a hash function is
like a hashing algorithm say so for
instance you have the common ones are
for instance murmur hash xx hash et
cetera so for each one you want to use
you'll have to well either install a
Python package but then you can't use it
in insight on because it's it's going to
be too high level and it's not going to
be fast enough or you can actually take
the source code compiled locally and
then try to build it and see if it works
and it's wrecked like that but actually
that that's a bit like fixed time well
if you use
do it in rust you can just like imported
given module Hill going to be billed
fine and then you can just use it
directly so this is a nice well it makes
experimentation much faster another
thing is if you want to make this
talking count counting parallel for
instance all you had to do here is that
so for instance here this is our data
set of documents normally what we do we
apply we map for each document to apply
some pipeline so for instance here with
tokenizing rehash and then if you want
to do is parallel essentially here we
just had to use a parallel iterator and
basically is going to multi-threaded
without much effort on on my side so
here for instance the comparison of the
scikit-learn version of so this is the
speed in in megabytes per second of text
and then the d text is just a single
thread it's already like significantly
faster and then you can also essentially
use multiple cores so so to summarize we
have a simple so basically it's a
package for simple NLP in rats with
python bindings we have like some of the
features i talked about RSS tokenization
talking counting there is also say
stemming and some string edit distances
so you can actually install it with pip
there are binary wheels for four
different platforms so you will not when
you use it you will not actually know
that it's done in rest because it's just
a binary package oh it's still in our
first um so the api is still going to be
movie bit but so this is just like an
experiment of how you can write Python
bindings for us a few a few more ideas
of where to go from here so for instance
what you can do is you can build web
assembly binaries from from the rest
package who knows who heard about
assembly yeah so web assembly is
essentially a binary format that you can
run inside the browser so for instance
you can call it from JavaScript so this
would allow for instance to use the core
of this package from JavaScript and more
interestingly there is there was a
project that aimed to build actually C
Python and numpy and all this
basic like core core scientific packages
into webassembly so you can run inside
robbers browser so this package this
project is called piyo diet and the
question is can we actually use the
binaries we will previously there as
well so that would mean that you can
actually say you have a web page you can
apply it organization on some on some
texts you see on the web page inside
your browser and so this is all
essential experimental ideas it hasn't
been that done yet
I mean but it's just like ideas of nice
things we can try to do and also there
is another project called bosmer
I you and essentially what it allows you
to do is from Python to run this
webassembly binary the nice thing about
it is that it means that basically your
your code is going to run on any
platform so for instance you you you
build the binder once and it should
essentially run Linux Mac Windows etc
but also say on on some non-standard
architecture such as arm or or etc well
less Western or losing so this could be
an interesting like in the future this
could be an interesting way of actually
a building a platform independent Python
will another interesting projects a bit
in the same ecosystem are for instance
respite on so this is an implementation
of Python interpreter in rust so it's
it's aims to be exactly the same as C
Python but in rust and personally I'm
also attached to a project called argmin
so this essentially does a numerical
optimization in rust with Python
bindings so for instance in my
application if you look at machine
learning libraries they often like the
classical machine learning libraries
they often use their l-bfgs optimizer so
this optimizer comes from Sify and it's
essentially I don't know maybe thousand
lines of Fortran code that nobody has
really touched in a while and in
particular for instance you cannot use
it with quotes 32 and so it's a bit
difficult to iterate like to improve
like to to iterate there and one of the
go
could be to expose this optimizer
written in rust from Python and use it
for instance in machine learning
libraries other so I have been
developing Python for a long time before
I went to experimenting with rust and
just a few observations I made while
just changing languages so automatic
formatter tools are really good so so in
rust you have this cargo format in in
Python the coolant is black and it's
really it's it's actually interesting to
see what happens if everybody uses it so
in drastic assume everybody used
therefore matter I think in Python if
everybody started to use black that
would be like significant improvements
so there is that the way if packages are
versions are pinned in in packages is
interesting as well so for instance in
rust you will you take one package you
will have fixed dependencies right so
for instance you can I don't know you
take your package it depends on on a
version of numpy and it's only this
version and then a different package if
you just all at the same time it it can
depend if ur intrusions in the PI so
that potentially means that you will
have it to install twice the same thing
so in iTunes it's obviously not going to
work but but there is some interesting
ideas there and I guess some of them
maybe are solved by tools like poetry or
pipe and etc so I mean just some
thoughts I guess my tendency was to use
actual dicks for everything because like
in Python this is the basic structure
and you know it's just you use
everywhere well essentially if you think
about it more as a as a as a as a
mapping between one type and another
type then you think that maybe in some
cases this is not the best thing and
actually you start to realize that when
you for instance type your item code and
finally a better type inference with pie
pie or seitan would be nice that that
would and particularly involve having
types in in the course and fake Python
libraries such as
non-pilots i buy which are currently
missing but if if you build your third
party like your user code on that you
cannot I mean types are not going to be
that useful unless unless all your
dependencies are
that will have to have type sanitation's
well in conclusions essentially using
rustic extensions for core elegance can
make quite scientific might own better
so I guess the same applies to to the to
the talked about Julia previously be
young the actual performance yet from
from just using a different like
compiled language well in this case you
also have access to the whole this whole
new ecosystem and it's interesting to to
just be aware of that and to know okay
well we need to solve this problem how
did people in this ecosystem solved it
previously or already and of course
because Python has a has a history of
wrapping different codes for in Fortran
C etc if you have some feedback on the
rust numpy package in terms of API that
would be very welcome and of course
there's another different interesting
project that could be made where we're
writing rust extensions could be useful
for instance for parsers so for instance
there is the open ml project which which
is which collects data sets their can be
used for machine learning so this is for
instance used in psychic learn currently
and there is a this so this project uses
the are format to include the data and
the metadata and the parsers we have
right now in pure Python are really slow
which means that when you actually try
to load the data set and psychic there
is going to be slow so in that case for
instance writing parsers again writing
parsers insight on is not something
that's like very how do you say it's
well very nice so in that case using bit
and the different language could be
interesting as I mentioned previously I
mean for instance a batch arrow has also
a rest implementation etc so I think
I'll stop here any questions
[Music]
[Applause]
great audience applause without queue
thank you so much for this I think it
was the only person who had never heard
of rust but I felt that this even though
this top was he's very useful to me I
saw a lot of engaged faces so we have
since you were so kind to finish early
we have more time for Q&A I already see
a first hand anyone else okay
sorry I need to run to give you the mic
yeah thanks for the talk and just
curious if you have try a similar
approach with C++ no Salman's
measurements and stuff I mean because I
I really like rest but leaving aside all
the webassembly
I didn't see the gain of using rusts
many says for me at least maybe naively
C++ will be closer to what C offers in C
Python so that's why I'm always curious
why go into the right direction to bind
yet another language to to improve
Python just curious I mean I know that
is better for us if we have more
languages and stuff but just give what
is your stand of doing the same thing
with C++ and why not this kind of it
yeah thank you for the question
so indeed I haven't talked about C++ too
much because in particular I don't have
any experience with C++ so I think a lot
of what I said also actually applies to
C++ and I think I mean modern C++ is
also very nice and has a lot of like
good things so it's not like you know
let's say there are some some some nice
things in rust there are some nice
things in C++ so for instance rust has
this in terms of safety it's a bit
better because the like the you have
this memory management which avoids a
certain number of like errors or SEC
faults etc on that aside maybe the the
learning curves a bit like more
difficult I mean I think it's yeah you
know there is no one solution to
everything so it is good to have a
choice and yeah so in my case I was a
bit also attracted by the web assembly
side but
I was wondering if you have any
knowledge how the rust compiler deals
with GPU architectures or does it so I
mean rust is based on LLVM so I guess
you
I mean Toby understand it that's not
like really something I know a lot about
but I mean I know people are writing
things in rust for TVM and I think it
has some GP backends but yeah so more
questions thanks for talking in
combining rust in Python what did you
find to be kind of the hard part of
getting the play together particularly
the two different memory models where
their particular sticking points where
they either couldn't or didn't see the
one to play nice well let's say so far
so this project is kind of a side
project for me so I haven't like spent
that much time on it and like I think if
they spend more time on it I would I
would have encountered more and more
issues that you mentioned so so far like
the experience have been more or less
smooth but it's also like this whole
thing of doing a rust extension for
Python it's fairly new so things are a
bit still experimental and I think if
more people use it and try to build
things it will be be in better shape
overall but but yeah but the fact that
at least you don't have to handle memory
handle the memory management on the
rough side is a nice thing because like
it means that there is no garbage
collector but the same time you don't
have to allocate the allocate things
manually which is always a problem for
me when I'd like to see Python like C
you would to remember to increment
decrement so like reference counting but
yeah I think I think you really need a
project that where you work work on it
full-time to actually understand the
limitations
[Music]
hence no hands no more questions you
don't have to ask questions but he's
from Paris so this is you know like your
last chance no
okay very good thank you so much thank
you
[Music]